koch institut heute ist dienstag der 28
april 2020
heute ist auch wieder professor wieder
gesprächspartner der präsident des
robert koch instituts wie üblich erst
das statement und danach die fragen der
medienvertreter famila bitte ja guten
morgen meine damen und herren lassen
nämlich kurz das wichtigste
zusammenfassen bevor wir uns im detail
die lage in deutschland anschauen
in den letzten wochen wurden rund 2000
fälle pro tag an das robert koch
institut übermittelt
und das war tatsächlich schon deutlich
weniger als in den vorwochen und
vorgestern und gestern wurden rund 1000
fälle pro tag an das robert koch
institut übermittelt wobei man natürlich
hier immer im kopf haben muss dass wir
nach dem wochenende einen melde verzug
mit einberechnen müssen die
produktionszahl r liegt momentan bei
etwa 1,0
aber so wie wir das auch immer wieder
feststellen gibt es große regionale
unterschiede im mittel heißt das aber
dass momentan etwa eine infizierte
person eine weitere mit dem saas corona
würges 2 ansteckt in deutschland auch
die anzahl der neu übermittelten
todesfälle ist weiterhin hoch
es wurden immer noch zwischen 100 und
300 fälle todesfälle pro tag übermittelt
und das zeigt sich dann auch in dem
anstieg der sogenannten fall
verstorbenen anteils der liegt in den
letzten wochen und der ist heute bei 3,8
prozent
auch ist es so dass wir weiterhin von
ausbrüchen in krankenhäusern oder in
alten pflegeheimen hören gut ist nach
wie vor dass die kapazität in den
krankenhäusern groß ist das heißt also
wir haben keinerlei engpässe wir haben
ausreichend intensivbetten und
beatmungsgeräte genau ich betone neben
nach der derzeitigen situation können
wir auch keine engpässe prognostizieren
das hängt natürlich davon ab dass wir
die anzahl der neuerkrankungen in den
nächsten tagen und wochen auch unten
halt
also dass diese nicht wieder ansteigen
denn dann reichen die kapazitäten aus
aber eben nur dann kurz einen blick in
die welt bevor ich mich dann mehr im
detail der situation in deutschland
widmen
in deutschland und das ist der stand vom
28 04 00 uhr und der stand der anderen
länder der ist ja immer ein wenig
verzögert zeitverzögert dass es der 27
14 uhr ein paar kennzahlen damit sie das
auch in den vergleich zu deutschland
setzen können in den vereinigten staaten
wurden bis dato und 966 1000 fälle
gemeldet und dort liegt die anzahl der
toten unter den gemeldeten fällen bei 57
prozent das sind rund 55.000 personen in
den vereinigten staaten in spanien
hier wurden bislang rund 210.000 fälle
gemeldet und hier ist die anzahl der
todesfälle 23.000 rund hier liegt also
die rate bei 11,1 prozent
und wenn wir uns das vereinigte
königreich anschauen dann wohnen dort
bislang rund 153.000 fälle gemeldet
davon rund 20.000 todesfälle
dann ergibt das eine prozentzahl unter
den gemeldeten und 13,6 prozent
wenn wir uns deutschland im vergleich
dazu anschauen
hier haben wir rund 156.000 300 fälle
gemeldet und darunter wurden uns zur
kenntnis gegeben 5900 todesfälle
das sind 3,8 prozent also im vergleich
zu den anderen ländern sind das zahlen
die ganz gut aussehend momentan weltweit
sind rund 2,9 millionen menschen als
kurve 19 erkrankt identifiziert worden
und wir wissen dass nahezu alle länder
betroffen sind von dieser pandemie und
so wie wir das in den letzten wochen
auch gesehen haben ist das haupt
ausbruchsgeschehen vor allen dingen
aktiv zur zeit in europa und in
nordamerika
und wie immer der hinweis dass sie die
ausführlichen detailzahlen ja täglich
upgedatet auf den seiten der
weltgesundheitsorganisation des
europäischen zentrums für disease
control als auch natürlich aus den
seiten des robert koch-instituts
nachschlagen können jetzt zur situation
in deutschland etwas detaillierter
betrachtet ich sagte schon dass wir bis
28 40 uhr 156 1337 cupid fälle
übermittelt bekommen und das sind rund
1100 44 mehr als das gestern der fall
war
darunter liegen insgesamt 5900 13
todesfälle
das sind 163 mehr als am vortag
und wir haben eine gesamt inzidenz das
vorkommen also pro 100000 das liegt in
deutschland bei uns 188 fällen zur zeit
da gibt es regionale unterschiede
das ist nach wie vor so bayern hat
momentan 3 117 fälle pro 100.000
einwohner und mecklenburg vorpommern 42
fälle pro 100.000 einwohner
die zahl der gelesenen schätzen wir
momentan auf rund 117 1400 tschuldigung
ich habe gerade ein technisches problem
verursacht wir müssen das wir lösen das
sofa wie lösen jedes problem ich habe
das falsch geklickt
weil ich weiter sprechen oder sich der
kunde
solange es kein computer virus ist ist
das alles lösbar schnell
sie stehen
aber da ich kann doch hier nicht
anklicken ich habe es immer hier
gepflegt
ich glaube am rande geklebt dass ich die
sturmschäden im raum zählt das deswegen
habe ich da oben drauf betont dass man
das problem also ich kann so lud hier
gehen aber da drüben fehlt ok dann
machen wir es erstmal heute so wir
können weitermachen vielen dank
tschuldigung für die technische panne
also wir hatten die zahl der chinesen
mit 117.000 400 geschätzt momentan
startet heute und ihre produktionszahl
liegt auf etwa 1 sie wissen auch dass
die fallzahlen und die zahl der
gelesenen täglich aktualisiert werden
und zwar können sie die sehr einfach
sehen auf unserem dashboard unter https
doppelpunkt / krone.at idee dort finden
sie die daten immer aktualisiert und
können sie auch weiter die daten
anschauen was sehr wichtig ist weiterhin
gibt es den situationsbericht den wir
auch täglich updaten auf unserer
homepage schauen wir uns die fälle in
deutschland noch mal etwas genauer an
bei rund vier von fünf der fälle haben
wir klinische informationen also rund
80% 125000 hier ist es nach wie vor so
dass husten mit 50 prozent und fiebere
mit 42 prozent die häufigsten
berichteten klinischen symptome sind
schnupfen etwa jeder fünfte 21 prozent
und geschmacks und geruchs verlust
werden auch häufig berichtet das
erfassen wie er seit letzter woche erst
systematisch über den meldeweg 17
prozent der fälle wurden werden im
krankenhaus behandelt das entspricht
rund 21.500 fällen von den 124.000 die
wir dazu übergehen dazu die
informationen und vorlegen und auch eine
wichtige zahl rund 27 prozent der
übermittelten fälle von denen wissen wir
dass sie eine lungenentzündung auch
ausgebildet haben
die todesfälle in deutschland sind
momentan 5913 personen die uns bekannt
sind dass sie im rahmen einer kur wird
19 infektion verstorben sind
der anteil wie gesagt bei 3,8 prozent
damit ist die anzahl der todesfälle und
der anzahl der verstorbenen weiterhin
hoch das liegt zum einen daran dass wir
immer noch ausbrüche in alters und
pflegeheimen sehen und auch in
krankenhäusern und tier sind natürlich
vor allen dingen die risikogruppen
besonders betroffen
wir sehen generell sehr viele
erkrankungen bei älteren menschen und
die todesfälle die jetzt auftreten das
sind die personen mit menschen die vor
ein bis zwei wochen sich infiziert haben
oder krank sind
es sind auch noch viele kurven 19
patienten in stationärer behandlung und
natürlich müssen leider davon ausgehen
dass von diesen auch noch einige
versterben werden die verstorbenen
person waren im durchschnitt 81 jahre
alt und 87 prozent der verstorbenen
person waren 70 jahre und älter
lassen sie mich zum schluss nochmal man
sie alle appellieren oder an uns alle
appellieren dass wir diesen erfolg den
wir in den letzten monaten denn wenn sie
die zahlen vergleichen mit zahlen aus
anderen ländern dann ist das sicher
bislang oder momentan eine erfolgreiche
situation
lassen sie mich noch mal den appell an
sie richten dass wir das auch weiter
beibehalten das ist ein erfolg den wir
uns hier alle erarbeitet haben und es
ist uns in deutschland bislang wirklich
zusammen und das möchte die betont uns
allen zusammen vergleichsweise gut
gelungen durch diese epidemie zu kommen
bislang dieses virus ist ja nach wie vor
in unserem land und wird ja auch noch
monatelang hier sein aber wir haben
bislang einen erfolg zu verzeichnen und
den haben wir vor allen dingen den
mitarbeitern mitarbeitern des
gesundheitsamtes zu verdanken die ja
wirklich aufopferungsvoll mit einem
unglaublichen einsatz kontakte nach
verfolgt haben und dadurch infekt ketten
brechen kommen wir haben es aber auch zu
verdanken den verschiedenen maßnahmen
die in unserem land durch
und diese maßnahmen wurden frühzeitig
ergriffen aber sie wäre natürlich nicht
sie hätten nicht gegriffen wenn wir alle
uns nicht daran gehalten hätten und
diese maßnahmen umgesetzt haben sind ja
wir die bürger dieses landes die dazu
beigetragen haben dass die maßnahmen
auch greifen konnten uns allen ist
natürlich bewusst dass die situation für
unsere gesamte gesellschaft und die
wirtschaft in den vergangenen wochen
weiß gott keine leichte zeit gewesen ist
und wir alle wünschen uns natürlich
wieder mehr normalität eine neue
normalität für das in den letzten tagen
häufiger hören
aber lassen sie uns gerade vor dem
hintergrund von lockungen weiter darauf
achten dass wir diesen gemeinsamen
erfolg auch weiterhin verteidigen können
wir sollten gemeinsam sorge tragen dass
es eben nicht wieder dazu kommen dass
wir mehr fälle haben mehr ansteckungen
und dann natürlich auch wieder mehr
schwere krankheitsfälle wir wollen nicht
dass die fallzahlen wieder zunehmen wir
wollen nicht dass wir wieder mehr kurven
19 schwer erkrankte in unserem land
behandeln müssen
wir wollen nicht dass das
gesundheitssystem überfordert wird und
wir wollen eben nicht dass viele
menschen ankurbelt 19 sterben oder auch
an anderen krankheiten weil patienten
nicht mehr bestmöglich versorgt werden
können
wir wollen diesen erfolg verteidigen und
das schaffen wir auch wenn wir uns
weiterhin disziplinieren und an einige
regeln halten und darum möchte ich noch
mal an uns alle appellieren oder eine
bitte aussprechen und ich sage das ganz
deutlich das gilt ja für uns alle
das gilt für jeden von uns in dieser
zeit lassen sie uns soweit es irgendwie
geht weiterhin zu hause bleiben halten
wir uns weiterhin an die kontakt
beschränkungen halten wir weiter
mindestens ein meter fünfzig abstand
voneinander
hier ist es vor allen dingen wichtig
wenn es darum geht dass man sich
gegenüber sicht will das
steht oder sitzt weil das virus jahr
über tropfen übertragen wird das heißt
beim sprechen beim lachen beim singen
darum ist dieser abstand so wichtig
halten wir uns weiter an die husten und
niesen regeln
und wenn wir in öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln unterwegs sind oder auch
in einem geschäft oder in einem umfeld
wo wir diesen abstand vielleicht nicht
mit der nötigen sicherheit einhalten
können bitte tragen wir zusätzlich einen
mund nasen bedeckung und zwar um andere
zu schützen
also zum beispiel eine maske aus stoff
wws mund nasen bedeckungen wie wir das
zu nennen
es gibt immer noch viel das nehmen wir
wahr unsicherheit darüber wie man masken
trägt wann man masken trägt und welche
art von masken welchen schutz oder eben
keinen eigenschutz sondern nur fremd
schutz bieten und deshalb möchte ich
nochmal ganz eindrücklich empfehlen dass
sie nochmals sich informieren über die
webseiten des bundesministeriums für
gesundheit der bundeszentrale für
gesundheitliche aufklärung und natürlich
auch das bundesinstitut für arzneimittel
und medizinprodukte wo mit sehr guten
darstellungen grafiken piktogrammen
texten nochmal dargestellt ist wozu
diese masken nützlich sind aber eben
wozu sie auch nicht nötig sind wie
dürfen die die chance dieser masken oder
gehen den schutz den diese massen
anderen vermitteln natürlich auch nicht
falsch einschätzen
sie schützen eben in erster linie dritte
und mit ausnahme der sogenannten ffp
zwei masken wie wir für den
medizinischen alltag in erster linie
natürlich wünschen
schützen sie eben nicht einen selber
sondern die schützen vor allem andere
davor vertreten
mehr wenn wir das virus ausscheiden
würden wenn wir sprechen lachen oder
singen beim singen scheine so zu sein
dass die tröpfchen vor allen dingen
besonders weit fliegen dankeschön
vielen dank herr wähle dann kommen wir
jetzt zu den fragen wie immer eine frage
pro
medienvertreter und maximal eine
nachfrage
wir fangen an mit n-tv herr aritz ja wir
haben sie alles richtig gesehen habe
versuchen sich jetzt die gerade kinder
etwas genauer abzubilden oder sagen die
ablage wieder an die meldezahlen das
heißt haben sie ihren eigentlich alle
bessere entwicklung als dass sich die
realität adele hast verfahren darstellt
vielleicht was sie danach machen und wie
weit hier eigentlich die zahl dass nur
lukas verfahren sind ja danke für die
frage ob es natürlich vor dass für sie
hören wir dachten schon eine technische
panne hätte diese frage runde beendet
aber dem ist nicht so
das ist ein verfahren das wir ja über
mehrere wochen entwickelt haben wir
haben zum ersten mal das neue casting
berichtet glaube ich wenn ich das
richtig in erinnerung habe am 9 april
und haben dann ab 15 april das immer
sehr transparent publiziert in einem
unserer publikations medien online
medien das ist das epidemiologische
bulletin casting ist eine schätzmethode
die auch in vielen anderen
zusammenhängen auch von vielen anderen
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern genutzt wird um eben
die realität besser abzubilden sie sagen
mit recht dass die meldezahlen die bei
uns eingehen
die sind sehr wichtig die liefern uns
wirklich sehr sehr wichtige und
entscheidende information aber sie sind
natürlich auch mit ein paar kws
verbunden also da sind zum beispiel
melde verfüge es dauert manchmal das
dauert immer eine gewisse zeit bis von
der der erfassung eines bestimmten
patienten über das gesundheitsamt bis zu
uns die meldung kommt
es sind die zeiträume nicht immer klar
benannt also wann hat sich eine person
vermutlich angesteckt wann ist sie
erkrankt wie lange war sie erkrankt das
sind alles faktoren die man erst im
laufe einer epidemie besser berechnen
kann
also wir haben ja jahrzehnte lange
erfahrung mit meldezahl und von daher
sehr viel kenntnisse über die stärken
und schwächen dieser daten aber wir
haben in den letzten und zwar bis ende
märz ganz konkret haben wir uns dann
waren wir uns sicher dass wir diese
dinge berechnen können wir berechnen
rückwirkend quasi wann personen sich
angesteckt haben wir haben eine
durchschnittliche inkubationszeit von
fünf tagen inzwischen angenommen in
unseren castings und das haben wir ihm
anfangs nur aus berichten aus anderen
ländern ländern übernommen vorwiegend
natürlich china wo ist die meisten
berichte inzwischen aber warum die daten
eben auf unseren eigenen erfahrungen da
gibt es schwankungen aber wir sagen fünf
tage ist die inkubationszeit dann eine
wichtige zeit ist die zeit die
sogenannte generation zeit also wie viel
zeit oder wie viele tage vergehen bis
ein infizierter wieder einen anderen
infiziert hat eine andere personen sind
in deutschland schnitt rund vier tage
und darüber kann man dann auch berechnen
wie groß vielleicht die dunkelziffer ist
also wie für menschen wurden vielleicht
gar nicht über die meldungen erfasst und
über diese ganzen berechnungen schätzen
wir die die zahl der tatsächlich
infizierten in deutschland und daraus
ergibt sich dieses sogenannte now
casting und aus diesen schätzungen das
sind eben berechnungen schätzungen die
natürlich auf bestimmten annahmen
beruhen berechnen wir auch unter anderem
dieses r
also diesen faktor erdin reproduktions
faktor und der wiederum gibt an wie
dynamisch die situation ist also wie
viel personen haben in der vergangenheit
wie viele andere personen infiziert hier
berechnen wir aber die letzten drei tage
der meldungen nicht mit ein weil hier
die schwankungen einfach zu groß sind
die sogenannten konfidenzintervall die
uns also etwas geben über die
genauigkeit unserer berechnungen und
darum lassen wir die letzten drei tage
weg also dieses casting ist intensiv
beschrieben in den fachartikeln die wir
publizieren
und da kann man wahrscheinlich noch
weitere weitere details nachlesen ein
international anerkanntes verfahren das
auch einer
prüfung durch durch andere
wissenschaftler gut standhält vielen
dank
wir gehen zur taz herr kreutzfeldt
entschuldigung da bin ich jetzt gerade
verrutscht ist die taz ja ja ja wir
hören sie eine frage zum erklärt und
zwar beschreiben sie hätten sie den
berechnungen aus den vier tagen wird
also die tage davor aus den beiden tagen
findet das aber in den nächsten tagen
berichten der angucken habe ich nicht
nachvollziehen
diesen darf ich weiß nicht genau wie
genau sie das nachgerechnet haben aber
es ist so dass tatsächlich wir runden
jahr den erwert das heißt also nach
mathematischen regeln 100 man ja wenn es
unter 05 ist unter und über 0,5 hoch der
tatsächliche wert den wir heute konkret
errechnet haben ist 0,96 und das ist
gerundet auf 1,7 gar nicht so schlecht
gerechnet
der 21 ist so ist dass das berechnen da
sozusagen der erste der darum dass der
fall aus alter mitregieren angegeben
notiert und auch hass und dann zu sagen
irgendwie letzten vier tage ja also wir
nehmen wir haben uns dafür entschieden
wir haben ja ich glaub wenn die die
meldezahlen also die reinen meldezahlen
immer anschauen dann sehen sie das ist
ja immer solche also die zahlen stark
abnehmen am wochenende also eigentlich
über die ganzen wochen hinweg sieht man
dass am wochenende die zahlen abnehmen
das heißt also dort sind einfach melden
verzögert zu sehen die ihnen gar nichts
mit dem wahren geschehen zu tun haben
sondern die damit zu tun haben dass am
wochenende eben nicht so viel fälle
übermittelt werden und darum haben wir
zeiträume genommen von zwei mal vier
teilen oder insgesamt acht tage also
zeitraum der quasi länger ist als eine
woche und wir berechnen die neue casting
immer in vier tagesabschnitten und zwar
nehmen wir immer also abgesehen von den
letzten drei tagen die wir nie mit
einberechnen in das r nehmen wir immer
davor zweimal vier tage und berechnen
daraus diesen wert vielen dank das ist
im detail halt auch sehr kompliziert wir
gehen zur reuters herr wackelt nach
laufen und dann die bedeutung dieses
faktor ist nun die nicht wieder
freigekommen
es ist eigentlich wichtiger hinzusehen
erst mal halt
der fälle nachvollziehen kann also es
spenden kann inszenieren kann
die entscheidende der entscheidende
parameter der jetzt nur auf das weiß ich
nicht mehr so abend ein
sie haben sie haben das vollkommen
erkannt das ist ja ein punkt den wie
immer wieder betonen er ist eben ein
faktor dieser eine faktor sagt etwas
über die dynamik aus ist ein wichtiger
faktor
darum berechnen wir ihnen aber genau was
sie sagen ist natürlich eine andere zahl
die sehr sehr wichtig ist das ist nimmt
die zahl tatsächlich der fälle pro tag
und ich hatte das schon mal hier in ich
glaube vor einigen wochen hatte ich das
hier schon mal angesprochen
er kann ja zum beispiel eins sein wenn
wir 50.000 fälle am tag hätten nehmen
wir mal diese zahl bislang nie hatten
die höchsten zahlen die wir hatten waren
rund 6000 pro tag
aber wenn wir 50.000 pro tag hätten und
jeden tag wieder 50.000 dann hätten wir
über die zeit auch einen r von 1 das
heißt also er kann nur und das ist ganz
wichtig zu verstehen kann nur gemeinsam
mit anderen zahlen betrachtet werden und
die zahl der fälle pro tag ist genau
eine solche größe und den grund haben
sie ebenfalls auch genau richtig erkannt
der grund ist nämlich der dass wir wenn
wir unter einer bestimmten zahl sind
dann ist den gesundheitsämtern gelingt
dann alle infekt ketten nachzuverfolgen
und dann ausbrüche sehr schnell zu
beenden das ist ein ganz wichtiger
aspekt und darum darf man eben diese
zahl alleine nicht aus dem kontext neben
es gibt ein paar andere zahlen die noch
wichtig sind dass sich die kapazität
natürlich im gesundheitssystem das ist
die anzahl der testungen also wie gut
wie viel können wir testen reichen die
test kapazitäten aus und das sind alles
faktoren die man gemeinsam nur
betrachten muss und darum ist es auch
nicht hilfreich wenn auch in der
öffentlichkeit immer nur auf einen
faktor bezogen wird wir müssen mehrere
faktoren im blick haben und das haben
wir auch uns gut dass sie das
messerscharfe kanten
vielen dank wir geben uns kurz nach
befragt
die leistung der gesundheitsämter doch
mal um die denkt ja das ist natürlich
auch regional unterschiedlich
das sagten sie auch eben aber wir würden
mal gehen etwa von einer zahl von 1000
pro tag also grob ich kann das nicht
genau bestellten aber in dieser
größenordnung liegt dass es gibt
gesundheitsämter die leistungsfähiger
sind als andere
aber um diese zahl zu erhöhen wir können
nicht genau sagen wie hoch die zahl dann
wirklich pro gesundheitsamt ist denn es
gibt ja teilweise sehr komplexe
ausbrüche wir wissen dass es ausbrüche
gibt wo man dann pro fall
10.15 bis zu 20 personen nachvollziehen
muss und das ist kann er sehr
unterschiedlich sein das geschehen wir
das ist ja der grund warum wir die
gesundheitsämter ganz gezielt stärken
wollen das ist ein programm das er in
der letzten woche auch diskutiert wurde
je mehr chancen wir den gesundheitsämter
geben also wenn wir sie unterstützen
mittels digitaler tools mittelsperson
wir haben wir diese containment scouts
auch eingestellt die bestimmten
gesundheit ämter zur verfügung stellen
das heißt damit erhöhen wir ja die
chance und die möglichkeit der
gesundheitsämter mehr menschen
nachzuvollziehen dauern bis das eine
zahl die ich nicht so genau benennen
kann
aber klar ist wir müssen die
gesundheitsämter massiv stärken mit mit
allen möglichkeiten die wir zur
verfügung haben da ist viel unterwegs
und dann wird sich die zahl der kontakte
die sie nachverfolgen können eben auch
erhöhen und durch diese containment
scouts hat man natürlich auch eine fixe
flexibilität also man kann natürlich
dann auch die scouts von einem
gesundheitsamt von einer region in eine
andere verlegen wo sie dann entsprechend
dem geschehen auch stärker unterstützen
können
das ist wichtig dass hier eine
flexibilität ist und es ist wichtig dass
die funktionalität die ressourcen
einfach erhöht werden vielen dank beginn
zum südwestrundfunk herr kümmerer
schon das thema kapazität und
angesprochen erwidert ich würde gerne
noch den test carsten eingehen die noch
nicht voll ausgeschöpft werden was kurz
denn das rkw alles um die test
kapazitäten ikone abstrich tests zu 100
prozent aus zu sehen
na ja also wir selber sind wir in die
testungen nur mittelbar involviert also
unser ziel ist voll ist zunächst mal war
es das ziel wenn sie sich an den anfang
dieser epidemie zurück erinnern dass die
kapazitäten so groß so stark wie möglich
nach oben gefahren wurden dass das galt
sowohl für die krankenhaus kapazitäten
also insbesondere die intensivbetten als
auch die beratungsplätze das galt aber
genauso für die test kapazitäten und
unser ziel ist es natürlich dass diese
tests möglichst strategisch sinnvoll
eingesetzt werden wir verfolgen ja
während dieser wochen und jetzt schon
monate in klare strategie wir möchten
auf der einen seite die infektionszahlen
niedrig halten auf der anderen zahlen
die kapazitäten im öffentlichen
gesundheitssystem und im
versorgungssystem hochfahren und für uns
ist wichtig dass die richtigen menschen
zur richtigen zeit und schnell natürlich
getestet werden natürlich steht hier im
vordergrund ganz klar die menschen mit
symptomen und wenn sie über die letzten
monate schauen haben wir unsere
empfehlungen immer wieder graduell
angepasst in rücksprache mit ärzten mit
den ländern mit den gesundheitsämtern
mit fachgesellschaften damit man
möglichst zielgenau testet und
inzwischen sind wir haben wir ja die
werde quasi die die die schwelle der
testung immer weiter runter gesetzt weil
wir zum einen einfach mehr test
kapazitäten haben zum anderen aber haben
wir natürlich auch momentan wenige fälle
so dass man wirklich großzügig testen
soll damit wir möglichst genaues bild
kam das sind die fälle die quasi im
versorgungssystem auftreten also bei
ärzten bei hausärzten oder im
krankenhaus möglichst früh möglichst
viel testen um schnell patienten zu
identifizieren
der zweite arm der eine große rolle
spielt ist der arm im öffentlichen
gesundheitswesen
also nun ein patient identifiziert wurde
das dann möglichst schnell kontakte
nachvollzogen werden und die sollen
natürlich auch möglichst umfangreich
getestet werden um sie gezielt in
quarantäne zu stellen oder halt auch zu
isolieren wenn sie selber erkrankt sind
und da gibt es einen anderen bereich
noch und das ist ein bereich gerne rolle
spielt in den settings wie wir das sagen
also in den umgebungen wo besonders
viele wohlhabende menschen also menschen
mit vorerkrankungen menschen die
hochwald ich sind leben das sind die
pflegeheime die altersheime oder auch
die krankenhäuser und hier gibt es
natürlich auch immer wieder situationen
wo man lieber zuviel als zuwenig testet
um einen geschehen möglichst früh zu
erkennen
das sind eigentlich die drei bereiche in
denen wir testungen empfehlen
und wir haben auch natürlich arbeiten
wir kontinuierlich mit verschiedenen
menschen in dem bereich um neue test
strategie noch immer wieder zu zu
ermitteln
empfehlungen zu geben für test
strategien zum beispiel für pooling
verfahren und sonstige details die wir
eigentlich kontinuierlich bearbeiten und
sie werden es auch sehen denke ich in
der zukunft dass die empfehlung und die
wir zum testen ausgeben immer sensitiver
werden also das heißt der anteil der
menschen der getestet werden kann soll
immer sensitiver immer größer würden auf
die tatsächlich die tests sagen ja
auswärts nicht alles anstellt deswegen
ist meine frage wie gut ist die daten
nicht besser wenn sie die test
qualitäten naja also ein test machen
doch wenn man einen test kapazität hat
ist ist natürlich nicht das ziel ist
muss schon eine indikation dafür seien
aber ihr punkt den sie davor machen ist
genau der richtige wenn wir schauen wie
viel informationen über tests vor acht
wochen hatten und wenn wir schauen wie
viel information wie jetzt haben dann
sehen sie auch eine wirklich großartige
entwicklung wir wir publizieren die auch
im situationsbericht jetzt immer wieder
der tests positiv waren das konnten wir
vor einigen wochen gar nicht weil wir
gar nicht genau wussten wie viel test
durchgeführt werden das heißt die
datenbasis wird tatsächlich immer besser
und labor meldungen an das an das robert
koch institut wird ja auch vieles
beschleunigt da haben wir den letzten
wochen eine menge schöne gemeinsame
erfolge zu haben und auch die tests sind
eben ein indikator ein faktor dafür den
wir brauchen neben dem was ich eben
nannte neben der zahl und der zahl von
fällen pro tag
anhand dessen wir das geschehen in
deutschland einschätzen können also je
mehr zahlen wir haben die mehr
indikatoren für die dynamik von kurz in
deutschland desto genauer können wir
hier über sehen was geschieht und desto
besser können wir natürlich empfehlungen
geben das ist wirklich ein großes puzzle
das wir eigentlich in den letzten wochen
immer immer besser zusammen bauen
konnten und dass uns immer mehr
einsichten gibt das ist sehr wichtig und
das werden wir auch weiter fahren wir
haben auch unsere sogenannten client
systeme also das thema wo wir bestimmte
informationen über die klinik von
patienten haben über aktivität von
atemwegserkrankungen mit grippe wert mit
mit iq sari den ganzen systemen die ich
auch schon mal vorstellte erweitern wir
ja auch kontinuierlich und das heißt
also unsere möglichkeit das geschehen
wirklich im detail zu beurteilen ist
immer besser geworden in den letzten
wochen das ist ein toller erfolg
und dafür haben wir auch sehr vielen
menschen zu danken die das überhaupt
erst möglich gemacht haben
vielen dank wir gehen zu ndr wdr markus
grill testen und machen erste positiv
beobachtungen
in altenheimen plötzlich fehler
entdecken die bisher nicht bekannt sind
wie bewerten sie das symptomfreie testen
das ist ja wenn ich das richtig sehe ich
nicht die empfehlung des ärgers und ist
es auch nötig die erstattungsregeln zu
ändern bei dieser ist es so dass die
krankenkassen glaube ich nur bei
symptomatischen patienten ja also das
ist das was sie ihm sagte dass man eben
in bestimmten settings also gerade dort
wo im viele menschen leben die anfällig
sind oder von denen man weiß dass sie
wenn sie infiziert wurden
die krankheit verläuft die chance dass
die krankheitsverläufe schwerer werden
größer ist das ist einer dieser
strategien über die man nachdenken muss
ob man dort eben großflächige
großzügiger testet das ist vollkommen
richtig und das zweite was sie
ansprachen ist tatsächlich eine
problematik die auch von vielen gesehen
wird nämlich die die finanzierung dieser
dieser tests und das sind dinge die sich
momentan auch besprochen werden die
viele im blick haben und ich kann nur
davon ausgehen dass dort und hoffen auch
dass dort lösung in der nächsten zeit
gefunden werden
vielen dank wir gehen zum deutschen
ärzteblatt die frau eckert
ja wie haben sie die möglichkeit mit
nach dem examen und jetzt hab jetzt
anhand von gestern kritisiert dass
kinder oft angeführt wird obwohl es in
ihren die marken peaq für die
bevölkerung erwarte dass die verwendeten
behelfen
also wir haben immer sehr deutlich
gesagt dass diese masken nicht dazu
führen dürften dass man sich in falscher
sicherheit wiegt das ist ja ein punkt
den wir auch in unserer kommunikation
immer klar ausgedrückt haben also das
wichtigste ist nach wie vor das worauf
ich eben auch noch mal hingewiesen habe
abstand halten
eben diese kontakte möglichst gering
halten dann abstand halten wir sagen
also mindestens anderthalb meter abstand
halten
wichtig ist diese nies und und husten
regeln dass man also wirklich in die
armbeuge niesen eben nicht in die umwelt
nicht so dass top wenig weit fliegen
können und das sind die die grundlagen
die müssen immer weiter eingehalten
werden das ist wichtig und das betont
wir auch nach wie vor vielleicht
erinnern sich sogar ich glaube die die
erste das erste pressebriefing was wir
hier durchgeführt haben da haben wir
schon darauf hingewiesen auf diese
grundsätzlichen verhaltensregeln und die
sind nach wie vor wichtig und richtig
und grundsätzlich zu beachten
die mund nasen bedeckungen auch hier
nochmal hier haben wir deshalb eine
empfehlung ausgesprochen weil wir in den
letzten wochen ja neue erkenntnisse zu
dieser erkrankung gewonnen haben nämlich
die dass es durchaus einen teil gibt von
infizierten die das virus schon
ausscheiden bevor sie einen bevor sie
symptome zeigen
und diese menschen wenn diese menschen
also einem und nasen bedeckung tragen
dann reduzieren sie damit die chance
dass das virus auf andere übertragen
wird weil diese physikalische barriere
auch wenn es kein perfektes ist kein
schutz für die menschen ist es für die
menschen selber ist kein schutz
aber es schützt zu einem gewissen maße
dritte wenn sie diesen mund nasen
bedeckung tragen denn dann werden
einfach tröpfchen die mit dem sprechen
ausgeschieden werden nicht so weit
fliegen und das ist der grund warum man
diese warum wir diese mund nasen
bedeckung auch empfehlen
aber es ist ganz wichtig und ich selber
hatte auch in der letzten zeit immer
wieder mal erlebt wie wir menschen auch
falsch mit diesen massen um es ganz
wichtig dass sie einen nicht in falscher
sicherheit wiegen
und es ist ganz wichtig dass sie die
masten richtig tragen zb über nase und
mund und dass sie sie eben wenn es
masken sind die mehrfach verwendet
entsprechend heiß wäscht und bügelt und
so weiter und so fort das heißt alle
diese hinweise
die sollen die menschen wirklich nochmal
auf den websites und bei der bca dem bva
und des bundesministerium für gesundheit
anschauen
es ist wirklich wichtig dass diese die
die der wert der schutz dieser geringe
mehrwert der mit diesen masken verbunden
ist dass der der wird nur dann gelingen
wenn die menschen damit korrekt umgehen
und wissen dass sie sich selber nicht
schützen aber sie können eben für andere
eine schutzfunktion haben und je mehr
menschen dann in den öffentlichen raum
die sie masken richtig tragen also
diesem und mund nasen bedeckung desto
größer wird der schutz für die
allgemeinheit
vielen dank
wir gehen zur tagesschau haircut
ja wir hatten ja wir haben sie wenn man
sich die us daten anschaut oder auch und
abgleicht mit den maßnahmen die er zu
unterschiedlichen zeitpunkten getroffen
wurden welche machten sie den blick
jetzt mit diesen daten als besonders
sinnvoll und empfehlenswert für die
politik na ja es ist natürlich schwer
einzelne maßnahmen direkt einem effekt
zuzuordnen also ganz klar ist zunächst
mal dass dieses bündel von maßnahmen
dazu geführt hat dass wir jetzt zu
geringe infektionszahlen haben welche
maßnahmen genau wofür zuständig ist
hätte man natürlich nur finden
herausfinden können wenn wir in
deutschland quasi regional
unterschiedliche maßnahmen gefahren
hätten um dann zu sehen was effektiver
ist als das andere
nach unserer einschätzung sind alle
diese maßnahmen wichtig gewesen
man sieht sehr schön denke ich an
unseren berechnungen und das ist das was
was also uns alle vor allem sie erfreut
dass eben die menschen ja auch schon
vorher ihr verhalten geändert haben weil
sie gemerkt haben dass dort ein virus
unterwegs ist das dazu führt dass man
sich anstecken kann und wenn man
kontakte reduziert wer etwas auf gibt
also physische nähe ein wenig reduziert
dass man dadurch damit beitragen kann
dass die dass viren übertragen werden
alle diese maßnahmen haben einen effekt
gehabt was wichtig ist aber wir sehen
auf jeden fall dass die maßnahme oder
ohne unsere einschätzung ist ganz klar
wenn die maßnahmen nicht durchgehalten
worden für so eine lange zeit wären dann
wäre natürlich die zahl der infektion
wieder angestiegen deutlich früher
angestiegen das ist eine überzeugung die
wir haben
und die können wir sehen an den falz
hand in der reduktion der fallzahlen sie
sehen schon sehr schön wenn sie die die
fallzahlen anschauen denn verlauf dann
sehen sie dass immer zwei drei wochen
nach den jeweiligen maßnahmen immer noch
mal ein bestimmter abfall der zahlen
festzustellen ist das kann man schon
sehen sodass man also jeder dieser
maßnahme eine wirkung zu rechnen kann
wir werden sehen wenn jetzt die
maßnahmen gelockert werden
dann werden wir also hoffentlich wenn
wir keine zu starken zunahme wiedersehen
also das wird aber nur gelingen wenn die
menschen nach wie vor diese regeln
einhalten abstand hygieneregeln
händewaschen hat sie eben vergessen ganz
wichtiger aspekt niesen und husten
regeln und eben auch im öffentlichen
raum da wo abstand nicht garantiert
werden kann
und auch im beruflichen raum natürlich
dort wo abstand nicht garantiert werden
kann
diesen bedingungen zu tragen vielen dank
wir gehen zu medico direkt und wenn sie
netterweise noch mal ihren namen sagen
ja wir haben sie vielen dank
mal geht in richtung der
zukunftseinschätzung trägt er sich
getäuscht denn das fällt ja auch das bin
damit noch rechtlicher wirtschaftlicher
leistungsfähigkeit wie deutschland von
den usa
der kontrast ist ein auf geschwindigkeit
und schulungen der ausbau habe meine
frage geht dahin schätzen sie den
erfolgsfaktoren für die begrenzung
solcher auf woche aus büchereien und ins
in sonderheit wie was haben wir jetzt
verraten
in ländern in denen jetzt intensiv noch
nicht angekommen ist apathisch
das wird auch bekannt welches volumen
und welche geschwindigkeit ist dort zu
erwarten könnten darauf bis zum
eintreffen
sie werden verstehen dass ich das
wirklich nicht voraussagen kann
das ist nahezu unmöglich es hängt von
sehr vielen faktoren ab wir müssen uns
immer klar machen dass alle diese zahlen
diese zahlen die die wir vermelden das
sind alles offizielle meldezahlen und
die meldesysteme in den ländern sind
nicht alle gleich sie sind nicht alle
haben nicht alle dieselbe intensität und
wenn wir in viele länder schauen da
müssen wir auch ehrlich sein
viele ländern gerade natürlich auch auf
dem afrikanischen kontinent oder in
südamerika oder auch in einigen staaten
natürlich in asien doch sind die umfänge
der testung pro kopf gar nicht so hoch
die das ist gar nicht zu leisten wir
selber vom robert-koch-institut
unterstützen auch viele von den ländern
indem wir zum beispiel auch lehrfilme
verschicken wir haben dort wir haben ja
ein zentrum für internationale
gesundheitsschutz in dem wir unter
anderem den umgang auch mit mit
schutzkleidung vermitteln damit in
krankenhäusern dort die ausbrüche nicht
zugänglich sind wir schicken teilweise
hilfsmaterial wir machen ausbildungen
und wir kriegen ein gefühl für die
vorgänge in diesen ländern wir werden
das sicher beobachten und und dazu eine
einschätzung geben können tagesaktuell
aber die verläufe sind wirklich schwer
zu schätzen dass das das kann kein
mensch machen
wir sind eigentlich mehr als wöchentlich
in telefonkonferenzen mit vielen von den
kollegen in diesen ländern
wir sehen zum beispiel dass in südafrika
bestimmte dynamiken sind wir wir hören
von nigeria von bestimmten dynamiken wie
die sich weiter ausbreiten werden wir
sehen
wir haben letzte woche zum beispiel auch
mit einem kollegen aus indien gesprochen
der bestimmte indikatoren an gibt die
nach seiner meinung dafür sprechen dass
dort keine hohe dunkelziffer ist es sind
so unterschiedliche länder mit so
unterschiedlichen gesundheitssysteme und
auch vor allen dingen so
unterschiedlichen kulturen und
lebensgewohnheiten dass ich mich
wirklich mir nicht anmaßen kann hier
eine prognose abzugeben klar ist nur
eins dieses virus wird eben monatelang
in diesen ländern unterwegs sein und die
die anstrengungen die die infektionen zu
vermeiden werden eben auch noch
monatelang in allen diesen ländern eine
große rolle spielen vielen dank
wir gehen zu focus herr meier bitte ich
fürchte dass diese fragen schon gelernt
haben aber aktuell kocht die debatte um
ein konkretes anstreben der buchserie
von vergangenen sonntag ich will auch
mal interessiert kann es so etwas nieren
kontrolliertes anstrengen von herten
monat geben also wir haben eine sehr
klare meinung zu und diese meinung wird
eigentlich von den kolleginnen und
kollegen mit denen wir uns weltweit ja
auch regelmäßig austauschen auch ganz
klar wie stark es ist für uns nicht
vorstellbar eine kontrollierte
herdenimmunität hervorzurufen
dahinter steckt ein tiefes verständnis
auch wenn wir dass wir uns noch nicht
wirklich hundertprozentig verstanden
haben die krankheit aber wir haben schon
eine menge information über das virus
und dieses virus hat einige
eigenschaften die uns zu dem schluss
kommen lassen dass wir eine
kontrollierte herdenimmunität einfach
nicht
riskieren können ich sage es mal so das
eine ist diese hohe ansteckungsrate die
die die leichte übertragbarkeit das
virus ist schwer zu kontrollieren das
haben sie gesehen in deutschland mit wie
viel kraft wie es geschafft haben die
zahlen runter zu drücken und sie sehen
ja auch in anderen ländern
man man man darf die anderen länder auch
die länder die deutlich höhere todeszahl
als wir haben und deutlich mehr schwer
verlaufende fälle
die darf man natürlich nicht so abtun
dass sie dass wir irgendwie besonders
dass wir einfach besonders gut und
besonders clever damit umgegangen sind
sondern wir haben es eben sehr früh
erkannt wir waren schnell wir haben
schnell die leistung hochgefahren wir
haben schnell die kapazitäten hochfahren
darum konnten wir das bislang gut an
denn das virus ist ein 1 1 1 1 virus ist
ein binärer organismus der holt sich was
er bekommen kann das heißt mit dem
können wir nicht verhandeln wenn das
virus an einen wirt gelingt dann wird es
sich in diesem wird also in dem falle
menschen vermehren und wir können das
nicht kontrollieren das ist eine aus
meiner sicht eine ansicht die gefährlich
ist
ich würde sogar sagen sie ist naiv man
müsste wenn man über diese dinge
nachdenkt tatsächlich darüber nachdenken
wie viel menschen leben man in kauf
nehmen möchte wenn man das tut denn
dieses virus breitet sich sehr schnell
aus und wir haben das möchte ich auch
noch mal ganz deutlich sagen wir reden
ja jetzt über ein zeitpunkt wo wir immer
noch kein medikament haben mit dem wir
ganz gezielt diese virus dieses virus
angreifen können also ganz gezielt wie
zum beispiel ein antibiotikum gegen
bestimmte bakterien so was haben wir
nicht und wir haben immer noch keinen
impfstoff
darum ist für mich diese debatte nicht
fachlich nachvollziehbar
vielen dank
wir gehen zu bloomberg tv von kris
commons
frage sie müssten jetzt das mikrofon
haben
[Musik]
hallo wären sie ich habe fragen kindern
wie schätzen sie die aktuellen daten die
motive kommen das bewusstsein kindern
ein neues können kinder das virus
anderen menschen übertragen und sind
auch in deutschland und erwartet starke
[Musik]
kinder abgetrieben
ja das ist eine wichtige frage die ich
leider und auch tatsächlich meines
kenntnisstandes momentan niemand
wirklich fundiert beantworten kann also
der stand heute ist der wir wissen dass
kinder infiziert werden können das ist
klar
da gibt es keine zweifel wir haben
bislang sehr wenige schwere fälle bei
kindern das heißt bislang gehen wir
davon aus dass bei kindern die krankheit
keinen schweren krankheitsverläufe macht
den grund dafür kennen wir nicht und da
gibt es nur hypothesen wie die werden
dann in den nächsten wochen und monaten
auch die epidemiologische untersuchung
bestätigt klar ist aber jetzt schon dass
natürlich kinder auch andere menschen
infizieren können
aber ob kinder ein besonders hohes maß
an infektionen hervorrufen oder weniger
die daten die uns zur zeit zur verfügung
stehen sprechen nicht dafür dass kinder
besonders stark andere mit menschen
infizieren können kinder sind aber
insofern und kann natürlich abhängig vom
alter 1 1 eine möglichkeit andere zu
infizieren will sich natürlich nicht an
die abstands jährigen halten in dem maße
weil sie natürlich in dem maße einfach
anders
miteinander umgehen und und weniger
achtsam sein werden zumindest je nachdem
von welchem alter gesprächen insofern
können sie also dass wir uns dann schon
weiter tragen und natürlich brauchen
kinder in betreuung und also je nachdem
welche malte wir sind und so weiter so
dass dann auch die abstandsregeln
teilweise schwerer einzuhalten sind
das war sie berichten gestern ist
tatsächlich eine das gestern kam eine
warnung von einer patriotischen
gesellschaft aus dem vereinigten
königreich dass bei einigen kindern
bestimmte entzündung schein
erscheinungen festgestellt wurden erst
mal nur ein symptom und man weiß die
symptome hat man jetzt erst mal
festgestellt das ist sehr gut dass das
sehr rasch bekannt gemacht wurde so dass
jetzt in vielen teilen der welt eben
auch geschaut wird auch bei kindern
irgendetwas entsprechendes auftritt aber
es ist ein symptom von entzündungs
erscheinungen von gm bislang nicht weiß
ob es überhaupt vermehrt vorkommt das
heißt das muss jetzt erst mal angeschaut
werden
das dass das ist wichtig dass wir dieses
frühe signal bekommen haben von den
kollegen in im vereinigten königreich
und also weder wissen wir ob es jetzt
vermehrt vorkommt oder nur zufällig mal
eine lokale häufung gewesen ist und das
zweite ist man weiß noch gar nichts
darüber ob das irgendwas überhaupt mit
19 zu tun hat ja also zunächst mal eine
eine beobachtung die muss jetzt
untersucht werden und das ist der
aktuelle stand der dinge werden wir in
den nächsten wochen erfahren ob das
etwas mit 19 zu tun hat vielen dank wir
gehen zu dpa/dpa hsdpa die pr-frau groß
er will nun möglichst sollte man kurz
nach was sind bei den produktionszahlen
der anstieg sieht man da vielleicht auch
ostereffekt oder wie ist das zu
interpretieren
und da ist dieser anstieg mich auch dass
wir doch noch den weiteren anstieg von
er über alles rechnen müssen dass die
kanzlerin hatte als ziel ausgegeben oder
ja also die effekte von von bestimmten
zeiten würden wir noch nicht sehen wir
sehen effekte eigentlich frühestens zwei
bis drei wochen nach einer bestimmten
maßnahme
und es ist eben immer schwer bestimmte
effekte nur auf einen aspekt
zurückzuverfolgen
das ist das ist definitiv nicht so
trivial aber ich sage es noch mal die
zahlen sollte unter 1 bleiben das ist
das große ziel
je weiter sie unter 14 spiel raum haben
wir aber es gibt eben andere zahlen die
auch wichtig sind und die anderen zahlen
sind unter anderem die wirklich die
fallzahlen pro tag das sind ganz ganz
wichtiger aspekt wir müssen das alles im
zusammenspiel sehen es wird nie so sein
dass ein faktor alleine dazu führt dass
man wieder völlig andere maßnahmen
durchführt oder nicht wir müssen das
immer im gesamtkonzept betrachten und
ein zweiter aspekt den wir bitte auch
nicht vergessen
diese zahl die wir ausweisen ist die
durchschnittliche zahl über ganz
deutschland und es gibt in deutschland
natürlich lokal unterschiedliche
geschehen es gibt in deutschland zahlen
da ist er weit höher als 1 und es gibt
bereiche wo er eben deutlich unter 1 ist
das heißt das müssen wir auch immer im
kopf haben ich möchte wirklich nicht
dass die debatte auf diese sr zu stern
sehr fokussiert wird nur eine messzahl
von vielen ist und noch mal
sie ist eine messzahl für ganz
deutschland mit einem gewissen
konfidenzintervall also einer fehlerrate
auch versehen aber eine wichtige messe
aber nicht die alleinig selig machen
vielen dank wir gehen zu mißlbeck wenn
sie nochmal die redaktion dazu sagen
bitte das ist der erste nachrichten ging
es gewöhnlich ja wenn man sie meine
fragen verstorbenen anteil der der ist
regional sehr unterschiedlich ich habe
jetzt einfach mal berlin verglichen in
der ligue dabei um 2% button fast fünf
prozent dafür muss ich passend momentan
also dass ich denke das können wir
anhand der meldezahlen sehen ich es
könnte sein das weiß nicht genau könnte
sein dass wir dort vor allen dingen eben
auch ausbrüche in altersheimen
pflegeheimen hatten die dann dazu führen
dass gerade in der altersgruppe
besonders viele menschen verstorben sind
das ist aber nur eine spekulation
momentan aber diese diese antwort
könnten unsere zahlen ihn sicher liefern
nochmal die hausärzte sollen möglichst
sensitive testen das heißt also wenn
schon kleinste klinische erscheinungen
sind die darauf hindeuten dass
vielleicht eine kurve 19 infektion im
gange ist
lieber einen patienten zu viel testen
als ein zuwenig die sollen nicht
möglichst viel testen also das ist nicht
die aussage gewesen dass jeder der in
die praxis kommt getestet wird sondern
die menschen die zum einen symptome
haben die mit kurve den zusammenhang
stehen und das möglichst
niedrigschwellig also lieber früher
testen als als zu eng die kriterien
fassen und natürlich auch menschen die
zb zum arzt kommen und die ihnen sagen
ich war mit einer bestimmten person
zusammen von der ich denke dass sie
krank gewesen ist oder von der ich weiß
dass sie krank gewesen ist
dann soll natürlich auch lieber
schneller als später getestet werden
also jederzeit verzug erschwert halt das
finden von sekundär fällen und jeder
zeitverzug bei der testung sorgt dafür
dass die chance dass andere menschen
nicht anstecken können einfach wächst
also früh testen nieder schuldig testen
sensitive testen das ist die aussage
vielen dank weg hin zum bayern reporter
marcus reuter menschen anstellen können
wie viel machen sie jetzt trotzdem eine
schnell
der kindertag nun das sind
entscheidungen die ich treffe getroffen
werden von den politischen
entscheidungsträgern die kinder je älter
sie sind desto besser können wir
natürlich davon ausgehen dass sie sich
an bestimmte regeln halten
das heißt also gerade ältere kinder die
kann man wahrscheinlich leichter wieder
in der schule unterbringen und wir
halten sich mehr an die abstandsregeln
die hygieneregeln als es bei kleinen
kindern der fall ist das sind dinge die
sich hat die entscheidungsträger
überlegen wichtig ist natürlich vor
allen dingen das clevere konzepte
entwickelt werden und das ist etwas das
gilt aber für alle branchen aus meiner
sicht wir vom robert-koch-institut wir
geben ja bestimmte empfehlungen die
epidemiologische fundiert sind also
abstand halten händewaschen niesen und
husten regeln beachten und dort wo das
nicht in dem maße geschehen kann auch
mund nasen bedeckung tragen und es geht
darum jetzt wirklich gute clevere
konzepte zu erarbeiten damit wir in
diese sogenannte neue normalität zurück
gehen können und das wollen wir alle und
das müssen wir ja auch alle aber das
wird eben dann erfolgreich sein wenn wir
gute clever konzepte haben und ich weiß
das ist eine reihe von
konzepten gibt die in vielen bereichen
jetzt erarbeitet werden müssen nicht nur
in den schulen und das ist eine aufgabe
die ja auch in den letzten wochen
gestellt wurde nämlich in der zeit als
wir eben die kontakt reduktion und das
öffentliche leben stark zurückgefahren
haben
und genau in der zeit mussten sich die
menschen wieder verantwortung tragen
natürlich solche konzepte überlegen
vielen dank albrecht club war wenn sie
nochmal ihre redaktion dazu sagen bitte
alle knöpfe hören sie die viel regen
diese genannt haben abstand halten und
uns regel was auch noch und nasenschutz
kennen da springt die führen der
konkretisierung zu sehr viel die
mobilität also jetzt komm am ende raus
geschäfte über alternativen
unter acht nationen über 800 natürlich
bauen wir den berufen kinos dürfen mich
im moment sieht das robert koch institut
nicht in der verantwortung immer weiter
zu konkretisieren
es gibt eine unterstützung beim betreten
nur draußen offensichtlich bei der
übertragung sind die konzepte erreichen
müssen hinein politisch ausgefüllt
werden oder kann das
robert-koch-institut ihm nicht noch
weiter hilfestellung geben weil sie
blind nach man nach meiner wahrnehmung
auch die akzeptanz in der bevölkerung
herabsetzen und die will ich ja klar bei
über 800 also unsere rolle ist ja die
dass für empfehlungen geben und wir sind
ja auch gar nicht zuständig für
branchenspezifische konzept wir geben
die rahmenbedingungen das heißt also
dieses einhalten von abstand genau also
diese vier dinge die sie da wiederholt
haben das ist das ist die aufgabe die
umsetzung schauen sie es wäre ja auch
gar nicht machbar es gibt so viele
lokale besonderheiten und so viele
bestimmte situationen in manchen
geschäften und in bestimmten setting
sind um welten wie wir im detail gar
nicht kennen
also hier sehe ich es fast als
kontraproduktiv an wenn wir zu
detaillierte vorgaben machen die dann
teilweise gar nicht umgesetzt werden
können das ist ja der grund warum wir in
deutschland zum einen gesundheitsämter
haben die sind ja auch in diese konzepte
natürlich mit involviert weil sie die
person vor ort natürlich am besten
kennen was ist überhaupt machbar
in bestimmten regionen oder in schulen
oder in geschäften und das zweite dann
möchte ich auch immer wieder gern daran
erinnern
es gibt in deutschland betriebsärzte und
betriebsärzte haben die rolle und die
pflicht dass sie die angestellten
möglichst gut gesundheitlich versorgen
und dass sie da
eben auch an solchen konzepten
mitarbeiten das muss man wirklich den
den menschen vor ort zumuten können und
diese diese verantwortung müssen sie
übertragen und wir geben empfehlungen
die die grundlage dafür bilden und dass
das ist der status und wir haben auch
diesbezüglich gar kein durchgriffsrecht
dank werden jetzt noch zu haben noch
zwei anfragen
jetzt gehen wir zu planet interview
der bohrer können es drehen sich auch
meine ferien und ist erkannt
diesmal will zudem aspekte sogenannten
kollateralschäden vor den medien
ich würde das spiel einmal die
arbeitslosigkeit interessieren weil es
dafür karriere relativ konkrete zahlen
gibt zumindest aus dem
gesundheitsbericht der taten von 2012 wo
es heißt das mit ihren prozentpunkt
wachstum der arbeitslosenquote
durchschnittlich ausbauen um einen monat
die zinsen für männern drei monate sinkt
die lebenserwartung meine frage daraus
resultiert finden solche oder auch
andere mögliche kollateralschäden des
lothar schon eingang in ihre
empfehlungen an die bundesregierung oder
es ist so dass ich das rk ii
ausschließlich mit der eindämmung der
alchemie schädigt also ich freue mich
dass sie unsere papiere so genau lesen
und das bestätigt eben auch dass wir
diese dinge natürlich im blick haben
das ist gar keine frage wir sind uns all
dieser sogenannten kollateralschäden
bewusst wie können sie noch nicht
quantifizieren wir werden sie aber auch
quantifizieren das gehört auch zur
wahrheit wir werden natürlich im
nachhinein auch das alles sehen und wir
wir wissen noch nicht genau was dort
geschehen ist das ist eine nie da
gewesene situation bei der wir teilweise
entscheiden müssen auf basis von daten
die uns nicht ausreichend um eine
fundierte
scheiben zu treffen das haben wir oft
gesagt neues virus neue situation mit
vielen unbekannten
und das haben wir im blick das ist ja
auch der grund warum natürlich
lockerungen auch notwendig sind wir sind
momentan hätten der situation dass wir
erst mal dieses virus diese epidemie in
deutschland beherrschen müssen
und dann schauen wir wie wir wieder zu
einem neuen normalität zurück gehen
können
was das konkret heißt wie konkret das
ausgestaltet ist dazu können wir
momentan keine empfehlungen geben
sicher haben wir momentan diese pandemie
sehr stark im blick aber wir wissen
natürlich auch dass die
vorsorgesituation in krankenhäusern
besser werden muss wir wissen dass
menschen zum arzt gehen müssen es ist
menschen auch es ist auch wichtig dass
die menschen wenn sie krank sind
natürlich zum arzt geniales parks sind
ja oft die krankenhäuser sind offen das
heißt also es muss hier etwas diese
dieser neue normalität wie sie sie
nennen muss eingang in unser leben
finden und für uns besteht diese neue
normalität eben zum großen teil darin
dass man sich an diese regeln hält der
abstand halten
hygiene niesen und husten regeln und
schutz tagen händewaschen
dann können wir viel von diesen
alltagsdingen die wir so oft genossen
haben auch wieder uns zurückholen
aber diese neue normalität mit mit
diesen vier regeln die wir wirklich
verinnerlichen müssen das ist nach
unserer jetzigen einschätzung der
einzige weg und zwar deshalb weil wir
keine medikamente haben gegen das virus
und keine impfstoff haben das sind die
rahmenbedingungen die wir momentan
leider nicht ändern können
vielen dank wir gehen zu radio münchen
frau schmidt
ja
jetzt hören wir die entschuldigung nicht
aus dem lot
ich konnte sie und wo sind die arbeiten
ja also wenn ich konnte ja kurs ist sehr
schlecht verstehen aber ich glaube ihre
fragen welche testsysteme wir haben
zurzeit also sowohl indirekt mit
antikörper als auch direkt mit einer pc
wie wir das sagen und wie valide diese
tests sind ist das die frage gewesen und
die dritte wo wir das nachlesen kann ja
also die erste frage bezüglich ist
direkten antigen nachweise alles
direkten virus nachweise mit dieser real
time pcr das ist ein test der hat sehr
gute qualitätsparameter und der ist wenn
er richtig angewendete oder die probe
muss natürlich auch richtig genommen
werden es gibt ein paar technische
details die man beachten muss also wenn
der lege artis durchgeführt wird ist das
ein test dessen ergebnisse eine sehr
hohe genauigkeit hat das ist so das hat
sich in den letzten wochen und monaten
sehr schön bestätigt und das wird sich
auch nicht ändern es wird aber zukünftig
wahrscheinlich auch andere tests geben
und dann muss man diese tests wieder
validieren validieren heißt man muss
dann eben möglichst viel wirklich
definiert positive und negative
probanden patienten haben um die
aussagekraft des tests zu prüfen
dafür gibt
unter anderem in deutschland ein
konsiliarlabor das von professor
thorsten geleitet wird der auch in diese
validierung doch immer wieder involviert
ist weil er so viel erfahrung hat
unschätzbar wichtige erfahrungen die von
der unser land sehr stark profitiert das
zweite das sind diese antikörper test
und da ist es definitiv schwieriger hier
eine aussage zu treffen
sie bemerken zu recht dass es viele
viele antikörper tests inzwischen gibt
es gibt viele tests die auch einfach
verkauft werden können
doch braucht es keine bestimmte
zulassung sondern es geht um eine
bestimmte zertifizierung und diese tests
haben sehr unterschiedliche
qualitätsklassen es gibt teilweise
wirklich schlechte tests die leider
trotzdem verkauft werden und es gibt
momentan nach meinem jetzigen
kenntnisstand kann ich zumindest einen
test von dem wir sagen dass sie eine
ganz gute qualität hat den test
verwenden wir das aber auch selber das
ist ein bestimmter elisa von einer
bestimmten firma und wenn sie fragen wie
man also um die anderen tests viele
andere testet zurzeit auf dem markt sind
die haben noch viele unsicherheiten und
das ist schlecht wenn es zb tests gibt
sagen wir mal nachweis empfindlichkeit
wenn zehn menschen wirklich antikörper
gegen das virus haben und der test
erkennt aber nur sieben davon als
richtig positiv dann ist das eine
70-prozentige sensitivität das natürlich
schlecht und test und da können sie sich
vorstellen wenn also drei von zehn
falsch sind dann können sie auch fast
schon würfeln diese tests geben
natürlich ein völlig falsches bild und
völlig falsche sicherheit die sind vor
allen dingen dann schlecht wenn daraus
eine konsequenz erfolgt zum beispiel
denkt man ja ich haben antikörper gegen
dieses virus ich habe das schon
durchgemacht bin vielleicht immun und er
zeigt einen falsch positives ergebnis
wo finden sie dass die werden getestet
von der whu zum einen es gibt bei der
feuerwehr zahlen darüber welche tests
welche parameter haben es gibt zudem
auch das bva
also eine schwester behörde von uns in
bonn
die auch die kriterien testet und
darüber etwas sagt und solange diese
zahlen nicht wirklich valide sind sollte
man sehr vorsichtig sein und ich kann
nur beten dass auch diese tests eben
nicht einfach verkauft werden von von
bestimmten herstellern ohne dass sie
eine klare qualitäts spezifikation haben
jeder mensch jeder arzt jeder apotheker
der einen solchen test genutzt oder ihn
verkauft soll sich gefälligst
rechtfertigen und soll demjenigen dem
der in den test an dient auch ganz klar
erklären wie gut oder wie schlecht das
ergebnis das ist die pflicht dieser
mensch und der müssen sie nachkommen
denn nichts ist schlimmer als falsche
ergebnisse aus denen man dann irgendwann
die rückschlüsse zieht die ja im falle
dieser krankheit auch recht drastisch
sein können vielen dank jetzt gibt es
noch eine allerletzte frage herr oder
frau ludwig wenn sie noch ihre
redaktionen dazu sagen und bitte kurze
frage und auch kurze antwort wir haben
schon ein bisschen überzogen
[Musik]
wenn einen wert von 1 während also wie
gesagt sie sollten in der öffentlichkeit
wirklich nicht immer sich ausschließlich
auf den erwert konzentrieren ist ich
sage nochmals ist ein wichtiger wert
aber neben diesem reinen wert erspielen
eben eine reihe anderer werte eine rolle
unter anderem eben auch um ganz wichtige
die anzahl der neuinfektionen pro tag
und das alles müssen wir im gesamtbild
betrachten und dann werden sich die
maßnahmen der nachrichten und das sind
immer momentane maßnahmen und hoffen wir
halt dass wir uns alle nach wie vor
wirklich an diese spielregeln halten
damit war diesen erfolg festhalten
können und dann ist nach der heutigen
prognose dann wird es ausreichend wenn
wir aber wieder eine starke zunahme von
fällen haben und das haben wir nochmal
ich sagst aber gerne selber mit in der
hand dann wird das nach heutigem stand
des wissens eben nicht der fall sein
also lassen sie uns einfach
diszipliniert den erfolg weiter genießen
ist vielleicht das falsche wort aber
zumindest lassen und uns festhalten und
dann werden wir sehen ob das alles
spekulation sind und wie wie die
kapazitäten in zukunft gebraucht werden
vielen dank sagt etwa tatsächlich am
ende
ich bedanke mich ganz herzlich für
diejenigen bei denen die jetzt auch bis
zum ende zugeschaut haben wir sehen uns
wegen des feiertags diesmal schon am
donnerstag den 30
april wieder und bis dahin bleiben sie
gesund wieder schauen